Fucking truly, don't have them if you're not ready to beat ass for them.
These days, people get stupid disrespectful with your kids.
Stupid disrespectful with your kids.
People give you stupid fucking looks when you're out with your kids.
It is not well received, not welcome.
But I don't know why there's this big push to.
For people to have kids. Because when you go out in the world with kids,
it's like you are just the bane of everyone's existence.
It feels shitty. You have to kinda,
as mom, like block all that energy for them and be like, no,
you guys can have fun, it's okay.
It's okay that you're here,
we're allowed to be here. Like,
there's so much trying to convince your children it's okay
when all these big scary adults are like
clearly so annoyed and angry that they even fucking exist
and have the nerve to be out in public.
So for fucking real, if you're not made of the thickest fucking skin,
ready to beat ass for your fucking babies,
don't have them. Just save yourself and everyone the trouble,
cause you're gonna raise little kids that get walked over
because you're not willing to stand up for them.
You're gonna put that it's. Just
think about everything before you have children,
including
and especially the world and society you're bringing them into.